I got a challenge for you this weekend
this one's gonna be the fifth challenge
of the year and I'm really curious
enough you're gonna take the time to
actually apply what I'm gonna share with
you my bet is 1% of you will apply what
I shared with you look for years I used
to do the following and then when I tell
used to do the following religiously
every 19th of the month every 19th of
the month I would run my credit okay
because my credit score back in the days
I know for was 488 for 95 for 99 if you
actually watch the life of an
entrepreneur video and you look at the
credit score that I'm looking at those
are my actual statements that was
looking at from years ago because I
saved every single one of them
I made an Excel spreadsheet and every
single week I will look at how much my
credit score improved on Equifax
Experian TransUnion I will look at how
much my checking account my money market
account my stock portfolio my mutual
funds my investments that I had my
artifacts that was about by my my art
that I was buying my paintings that I
was buying I would always track that to
see what was going on and eventually my
credit score went from a 488 to an 820
and the rest is history with the credit
score side but I applied that same
concept into three areas health personal
finance and business let me explain
health your weight whatever measurable
data you can get whatever the measurable
data it is that you are trying to track
maybe it's a time you're running for a
mile for two mile 5k whatever it may be
for that side maybe it's your weight
maybe it's your body percentage maybe
it's your you know the amount of how you
did with your diet how you feel energy
wise but it's got to be something that
you can track data with and you measure
it q1 which is quarter one of 2018 - q4
of 2017 and I measure - q1 of 2017
because sometimes is season to season
and I'm doing quarter two prior quarter
season to season would be q1 18 versus
q1 17 then quarter two quarters q1 18 to
q4 17 I'm doing that for my health and
I'm doing on my personal finance and I'm
doing that for my business all
the business side whatever data you can
pull up I'm talking specific data if you
come to my home office
I have screens I can't even tell you how
many screens I have with data all over
the office because I want to know
exactly how I measure against last year
this time two years ago this time and I
want to know exactly how we measured
this quarter versus last quarter and q1
season to season and so why is this so
important let me explain to you why do
you remember back in the days when you
took geometry and you would have this
formula and it would say here's what's
given solve this theorem if this
triangle you know this side is three
inches this is four inches how long is
this here and you were given well it's a
disagree angle and the formula is gonna
be this and the formula is gonna be that
and you go three score for score equals
you know X whatever it is right you're
solving for x and you would make a list
of all the things that are given that
you knew about and based on the Givens
you would solve for X or whatever the
answer is you're trying to figure out
for business is identical the same way
okay identically the same way there's a
guy named Billy being on baseball who
figured this thing out and came out with
the formula with a 19 year old kid on
what is the most important data to pull
up in baseball and they realize it's not
homeruns it's not doubles it's not
singles it's not triples it's not stolen
base its on-base percentage the more you
studied your your data of your company
your business whatever you're running
eventually you're gonna figure out what
trends and what data you ought to pay
attention to most to help grow the
company continuously month to month
quarter to quarter season to season but
you got to grab a paper and pen okay and
start writing as much data that you can
track from this quarter to prior quarter
and last season's quarter and ask
yourself which one of them did you beat
by what percentage and what are you
gonna be doing in q2 that's gonna beat
your q1 and q2 of 2017 I'd be so curious
to know how many of you will actually
take up this challenge other week and by
the way if you do take
the challenge of the week send me a
tweet at Patrick bit David I want to
hear from you on what you came up with
after studying the data of your business